would you be willing to not go out one
day an entire month yeah no you would
not
hi I'm Lisa gold I'm a financial
counselor and I will be reviewing three
millennial bank statements financial
counselors somebody who works with
people and small businesses on their
either personal or business money it
helps them to live the best life that
they can based on what they're making or
what they could potentially make being a
millennial means that you're probably
still pretty young and you haven't moved
up within either the corporate world or
a self-employed business or an artistic
venture you're just maybe not quite
there yet alright let's go let's look at
some millennial bank statements I am a
recent college graduate and I have a few
questions about my student debt and what
I should do with my money the very
little money that I have I recently got
out of credit card debt like really
serious credit card debt I'm currently
looking for help with my finances for
cost from relocating from New York a few
months ago I have some medical expenses
that came up unexpectedly can I look at
your bank statements I mean again lifts
streaming service and airline ticket
yoga studio makeup mostly everything I'm
seeing here is coffee and food mm-hm
yeah outside of my bills where most of
my money goes is food drinks and ubers
going out makes me feel like I'm
throwing money away but at the same time
I'm having fun so you're not throwing
money away if you have the money to
spend and you're mindfully spending it
in places that you want to go with
people that you want to be with throwing
it away might be we're gonna hang out
and I don't even like them and the food
here is crappy and the drinks suck I've
also done that okay what we're not gonna
do that anymore I had some unexpected
medical things come up some dental work
I had to have done there are expenses
that come up that we say are unexpected
but the reality is that you're probably
not going to live the next 60 years of
your life never having a medical belt
you're not in this predicament because
you went out and bought clothes and
shoes and went out to dinner and
trips you did that okay put a little bit
of money aside every month into what I
call a parking lot the reason I call it
a parking lot is because when you are
taking money out of quote-unquote
savings it's charged it doesn't feel
good you're like oh I was saving that
money and now I have to take it out and
out have my money saved anymore this
money is not for saving this money is
meant to be spent but we don't know when
and we don't know for what what rough
dollar about what do you say is good for
the savings account what would you do
with this money if you could do anything
with it what would you do oh you can
spend it you can't so what should you do
with this money I think you should start
building your safety net and I think you
should start building an account so that
you can move out you want things so list
them put a dollar amount next to them
one of the things on that list needs to
be my own place say this is how much I
make this is what I need to spend
monthly and then you're living a
priority centered life which is the best
way for anybody to live I have my car
loan and I have my student loans and I
have enough money to just pay off one
and I don't know if I should pay off my
loans or I don't know what I should be
doing with my money yeah okay do you
know what at the rate is yeah student
loans I think it's four point eight okay
let's just rate on your car less than
five so they're roughly the same yeah
okay paying down the student loan might
save you overall interest because of the
length of the term not because of the
interest rate but if you've got you know
fifteen years and you've only got Li
three or four on your car loan you're
gonna pay less interest even though the
interest rates are the same you're gonna
pay the less interest on the car because
it's short-term see what I'm saying
yeah and if you're gonna cut that time
in half then you're gonna cut that
interest in half as well
I don't think that you're doing as badly
as you think recognize what I bought I'm
paying for that I'm not paying debt I'm
not paying a credit card I'm paying for
this stuff that I needed I want you to
design your life
the way that you want it within the
parameters of what you make whatever you
have to do you can make more but for now
with what you have let's design
something that feels good to you
your biggest thing I think is the is the
weekend spending if you can spend 50
bucks a week less you can put an extra
200 dollars into your savings onto your
car payment or onto your student loan I
feel a lot more comfortable with my
finances now after speaking with Lisa
really helps me and I I think because to
see what its gonna be like to plan ahead
I think just being aware of how much
you're spent is it's a good start and
from here on I think I'm gonna try to
look at my bank account every Monday and
take it from there
[Music]